Justice League's production was marred
with controversy originally planned as a
two-parter the movie was severely
changed after the poor reception of
Batman V Superman over its troubled
history tabloids were littered with
rumors of rewrites directorial
replacements and humongous reshoots if
you're a fan of Zack Snyder's work then
like me you're clamoring for an ultimate
cut of the film we've seen from the
blu-ray release of Batman V Superman
that these extended editions can vastly
improve the film in quality and
coherence however Justice League doesn't
seem to be taking this path and with
poor profit margins on the movie it
seems unlikely that we will ever get one
that's why I've compiled this video to
discuss Snyder's original vision so that
your curiosity may be satisfied in terms
of what we could have got with that out
the way I'm definition and this is the
original Snyder coat script
unlike the theatrical release the film
didn't open on a terrible cellphone
footage of the worst CGI blunder in
movie history instead Justice League
part 1 as it was called began with Bruce
Wayne's journey to find Aquaman this
opening was meant to be similar to
Batman Begins and also sought out the
continuity error of Bruce fighting a
criminal on the rooftop clean shaven and
then having a full beard in the next
scene
Bruce would then exposit the dialogue
that we saw on the original teaser
trailer there is a stranger who comes to
this village from the sea he comes in
the winter when people are hungry big
fish comes on the king tide
I was last night
took I believe that an enemy is coming
from far away I'm looking for warriors
this stranger others like him
I'm building an alliance to defend us
from here Bruce shaves on the plane and
encounters a para demon upon reaching
Gotham mirroring this Wonder Woman
tackles a suicide bombers in London
however unlike the theatrical her she
fails to stop a secondary explosion
something that was also present in early
trailers well as there are no casualties
she still harbors a lot of the blame and
the film takes on a darker tone we
they're not introduced to Barry Allen
through his saving of iris and Martha
and Lois discuss Clark's death at the
forum before Martha announces that she's
being evicted from here we get a much
more fleshed out origin story for cyborg
we witness his life as a football star
and the horrifying car crash that killed
his mother and critically injured him
shown in the original trailers the film
then moves to Bruce and Diana discussing
the rejection of Aquaman in the Batcave
at the Daily Planet
Lois plays a much more vital role she
discovers how the parademon kidnappings
are related and cyborg antisepsis
knowledge deciding what to do next we
follow the character as he learns to fly
and control his power and the metal man
realizes that he can control the entire
nuclear arsenal of the world
however he fears for his humanity and
decides to swipe it away the film then
reverts back to the theatrical release
with Steppenwolf stealing the first
mother box from the Amazons his design
is similar to the original one portrayed
at the end of Batman V Superman however
he is much more intimidating here upon
obtaining the mother box he delivers the
following line
new Yonkers
[Music]
move utonium which was a speech that was
missing from the eventual release he
explains the unity and then makes his
way to Atlantis the Amazonian send
warning to Diana and she rejoins Bruce
to discuss Steppenwolf she informed some
of the first-time Steppenwolf attacked
the planet the battle scene plays out
similar to the theatrical release
however green lanten Zeus and Ares all
get lines and the characters play much
more important parts and their cameo
like appearances in the theatrical
release Bruce seeks out Barry
and Diana begins a quest to find cyborg
in Atlantis Steppenwolf attacks this
time however he is joined by parademons
which distract Aquaman and the villain
is able to attain the box willem dafoe
not Meera discusses Steppenwolf with
Aquaman and instills is to to you to
track down the Box parademons stork
cyborg in his home kidnap his father and
the team assemble and venture into
Gotham Harbor to take down Steppenwolf
the action scene plays out much the same
but this time it's got extended dialogue
and more conflict from cyborg as he
struggles to control his power the
battle ends at a stalemate but the team
begin to assemble as they discuss the
pros and cons of bringing Superman back
Lois wakes up from a nightmare and
reminisces all the good times that she
had with Clark a scene that was later
added to the opening montage song
flashback to the Batcave and Bruce
studies Superman's costume as cyborg
discovers the origins of the mother box
through virtual reality he's able to
investigate its history at the hands of
the Nazis in World War 2 which slightly
retcons the discovery of it in the
deleted scenes of Wonder Woman righting
the wrongs of his past Silas stone helps
the team to infiltrate the Kryptonians
ship and cyborg thanks him for it
Superman is revived and the commencing
battle that the Man of Steel has with
the remaining Lee devastates heroes Park
Lois Lane who is passing by at the time
hears this and runs to the confrontation
to save Clark from killing Batman
similar to how she did in the martha
scene of bbs this is where we would also
see cyborg telling the police officers
that they should probably move Clark and
Lois arrive at the farm and discuss
their engagement this scene was shown in
trailers but cut down for the theatrical
releases strict
one time of two hours we then joined the
league at the bat cave who discussed
their defeat while salfred humorously
mocks them in a sarcastic brash tone
this scene was extended and really
fleshed out that Diana should be the
leader of the league even if she
disagrees with the position overall it
would have built more camaraderie and
gave motive to Batman suicide mission in
the final act the league would then
embark on their journey to take down
Steppenwolf and we would see a much
greater journey in which Batman arms up
the other members Aquaman's conversation
is less humorous and he mutters honestly
I think we're all going to die
which is replaced with I don't want to
die in the final version this was a lot
longer scene in which cyborg laid out
the strategy and the team really bonded
before they went into what could be
their last day on earth
Superman journeys to the ship for his
suit he retrieves his blue and red one
and then goes to visit Alfred to
discover the league's plans Batman
blaming himself for Superman decides to
become bait and as he heads off on a
suicide mission the other leaguers
dissuade him and help the final battle
plays out much in the same way that it
doesn't at the at Racal release however
when separating the mother boxes cyborg
gets a glimpse at the nightmare vision
that batman hadn't bbs and we also
witness Darkseid the battlescape
also mirrors apocalypse and has a lot
more the hellish landscape that the
planet possesses now on earth the team
of course defeats Steppenwolf and decide
to create a league we get a much longer
ending in which Barrie gains a job at
the crime lab and Meara travels to land
to bring Aquaman to Atlantis Bruce
awakens at night to be greeted by a
Green Lantern potentially played by army
hammer he warns the Dark Knight of the
coming of Darkseid and we end on a
bittersweet note so that is my piecing
together of the original Snyder Justice
League script I've compiled this from
various sources to try and depict as
closely as I can to what we would have
gotten the final cut of course with
Warner Brothers interference we never
know if this could have been the
complete vision of the original director
but it's fun to speculate I'd love to
hear your thoughts on the original
Snyder cut so make sure you leave them
below and be sure to add in any other
rumors that you
herd or if there's an element that you
think I got wrong thanks again for
watching this video please subscribe to
my channel and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]